Social and Emotional Learning, or SEL, has
moved to the center of the educational
landscape, and there's much to like about
this. But for SEL to be successful,
advocates need to ask some tough
questions. The biggest: "What the heck is
SEL, anyway?" Look, it's easy to build
momentum by letting SEL mean whatever
someone wants it to mean. But for it to
stick, proponents need to be clear about
what SEL is — to guard against the vendors,
ideologues, and snake oil peddlers who
will insist that SEL is whatever serves
their interests. I'd urge advocates to
take care that SEL emphasize its
implication for character and
preparation for responsible citizenship,
partly to allay concerns that SEL could
become a squishy distraction from
academics. I'm certainly not the
authority on what the definition of SEL
should be, but I can say that a lack of
clarity will summon those eager to
promote their own agendas, and that's not
good for anyone — except the hucksters.
How do you think schools should measure
Social and Emotional Learning? Let us
know in the comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.